foreign
[Music]
seven years have passed since the Hunger
Games Mockingjay part 2 was released the
final film about The Hunger Games and
Katniss Everdeen those who feared that
this would mean the end of the stories
from panum can rejoice as a fifth part
of the film series is coming in 2023.
book readers among you will already know
the story of The Ballad of songbirds and
snakes but also for those of you who
haven't read the book today we'll take a
look at all the details concerning the
cast production and plot of the movie
adaptation
before we get into the specifics of the
new film here's a quick rundown on panum
in the continent's history PanAm
describes the post-apocalyptic continent
of North America which was formed by
natural disasters on the one hand and a
fierce War for raw materials on the
other it is divided into 13 districts
where today we would find Utah Colorado
and Wyoming the capital rules over the
other 12 districts each district has its
own industry such as the production of
clothing food or electricity they must
seed these to the capital however as the
districts rise up in Rebellion against
the Capital District 13 is completely
annihilated and the others are forced to
surrender to the capital Supremacy or at
least that's what the capital's
propaganda says in reality the
inhabitants of District 13 are hiding
underground and preparing for a new
Rebellion against the capital in order
to demonstrate its superiority over the
other districts the capital holds the
annual Hunger Games in these two
children from each district are chosen
and must compete against the other
children in a cruel competition to the
death yet these battles end up being the
Catalyst for the renewed Rebellion that
we see in the film series centered
around Katniss Everdeen The Ballad of
songbirds and snakes however Place 64
years before the events that we know
from the first four movies
currently there are already some names
in the cast list of the new film since
the characters will once again be very
young we will see a fair number of
newcomers though there will also be some
familiar Hollywood stars
the first protagonist is Lucy graybeard
like Katniss she is from District 12 and
was chosen as tribute for the 10th
Hunger Games what is unique about this
is her love affair with coriolana snow
yes that's right snow the latter
eventually becomes the infamous
President Snow Lucy loves to produce
music with her band Covey and this
Talent also helps her to find Rich
sponsors for The Hunger Games the role
of Lucy is played by Rachel zegler the
21 year old actress made her big
breakthrough in Hollywood in the part of
Maria in the musical film West Side
Story in 2021 whether or not she will
survive the Hunger Games it's something
we won't reveal here of course
however not everything will be about
Lucy one more main character is the
aforementioned coriolana snow the future
Tyrant was not always as cold-hearted
and brutal as in the past installments
snow is a mere 18 years old during the
movie's time and his cousin describes
him as a compassionate and kind-hearted
person yet he quickly realizes his
ability to figure out people and starts
to use this to his Advantage proof that
life scarred him at a young age can be
seen in the fact that his father died in
the Civil War and that his mother also
passed away a short time after thus he
and his sister grew up as orphans and he
was required to take responsibility for
others from an early age his name
coriolanus is by the way a reference to
the Roman general neus marcius
coriolanus like snow he gained his power
through dishonest means and lost it by
his own arrogance the role of snow is
played by Tom Blythe the young actor was
last seen in the film benediction and
also counts as a newcomer in Hollywood
we are particularly looking forward to
meeting the creator of The Hunger Games
although we should rather speak of an
unintentional Creator here that person
is casca highbotta he is the dean of the
academy which is the elite school in the
capital he created The Hunger Games as a
theoretical concept that was never meant
to be carried out however an ambitious
doctor at the Academy took the concept
and brought it to the public and thus
casca became known as the face of The
Hunger Games the cruelty involved in
reality and his personal involvement in
it led highbottom to become addicted to
Morphine playing the dean is none other
than Game of Thrones star Peter Dinklage
we couldn't have dreamed of a better
cast for a genius with a tendency
towards self-indulgence in keeping with
a motto I take morphine and I know
things
what would the Hunger Games be without a
flickerman in The Ballad of songbirds
and snakes however his name is not
Caesar but lucretius Lucky flickerman in
the 10th Hunger Games he is not hosting
the entire games yet instead he conducts
the interviews with the mentors and
tributes he is played by Jason
Schwartzman who most recently appeared
in Fargo in the French dispatch whether
there is a family connection between
Caesar flickman and lucretius was never
mentioned in the books
given that the protagonist is from
District 12 again we can assume that
there will be some other characters from
this part of panum as well three more
residents have been confirmed already
number one Billy Tope as Lucy's lover
there is sure to be a lot of possible
conflict with this character especially
considering that she also gets
romantically involved with snow in the
movie Hope is played by Valley of the
boom actor Dakota Shapiro we also get to
meet one of Lucy's band baits mod Ivory
Baird she's played by Von Reilly and
last but not least of course we have the
male tribute Spruce Lucy's counterpart
is portrayed by the Brit George Sumner
who last had a role in the TV series
this is going to hurt
a large part of the tributes has also
been cast already since the tributes are
children the actors are of course
relatively young and for many it is
their first role in a major Hollywood
film mizen from District 4 is played by
Cooper Dillon some of you may know the
German American from the peppercorns a
German Kid series lamina from district 7
is portrayed by Irene Bohm the 18 year
old played in the TV series Babylon
Berlin there she is the sister of the
protagonist Charlotte Ritter the tribute
of district 7 is played by 13 year old
Sophia Sanchez the young American model
has been diagnosed with trismy 21 and
became well known for her video Down
syndrome is not scary the district 10
tributes are played by Luna cues known
from the German TV show Castle Einstein
and Kell brookshite latter was last seen
in the German film The Young Chief
winnetu the final tribute is Reaper from
District 11 played by dimitria Bowl
among the tributes are of course also
the mentors from the capital and the
10th Hunger Games these all come from
the academy the top 24 students have the
honor of being mentors in The Hunger
Games for the female tribute Coral from
District 4 fastest Creed is the mentor
he's played by the British actor Max
Rafael for mizzen it is Persephone price
and she is embodied by Athena Straits
The Young South African with German
background has also made a couple of
appearances on German television lamina
from district 7 is trained by Pliny pup
Harrington he is portrayed by ayomide at
a gun for atagan it is his first
appearance on the big screen then there
is the male tribute from district 7
Treach who gets fipsenia sickle as a
mentor sickle is played by 18 year old
American Amelie hofuro meanwhile damisha
whimsawick is the mentor for the tribute
from District 10 and lysastrada Vickers
is her equivalent to the male tribute
from District 12. the two women are
embodied by Caitlin akan palumi and Zoe
Renee
production unlike most of the cast we
will see a well-known name sitting in
the director's chair as in Catching Fire
Mockingjay Part 1 and Mockingjay Part 2
Francis Lawrence will once again direct
the film for the production the team is
also sticking to the tried and true Nina
Jacobs and Brad Simpson Are Back In
Charge book author Suzanne Collins
herself is even on hand to handle the
screenplay while Michael art who wrote
Star Wars episode 7 the force awakens
and Michael Leslie are both providing
support Leslie wrote the screenplay for
the film adaptation of Macbeth released
in cinemas in 2015. shooting for the
movie is set to begin in the fall of
2022. it'll be shot in Germany filming
will take place primarily in the greater
duesburg heading in and cologne areas
anyone who wanted to be a part of the
film had the chance to apply until
August in fact the makers were looking
for more than 3 000 extras in Germany
alone this is certainly one reason why
so many German actors were cast however
the theatrical release is still some
time away as the release date is
scheduled for November 17 2023 of course
we will be keeping you up to date with
all the news about the production and
cast in our weekly news
needless to say the movie will once
again focus on The Hunger Games 63 years
before Katniss Everdeen PanAm is still
shaken by the Civil War which happened
10 years earlier for 16 year old Lucy
gray as tribute of District 12. it's all
about survival nevertheless her love
affair with her Mentor Corey Elena snow
seems to give her some Advantage during
the competition snow however is pursuing
his own goals he is out to restore the
family's honor after their Fall From
Grace during the riots he certainly has
his chance as a mentor in the course of
The Hunger Games and he soon recognizes
his talents which will later help him
become president in addition we are
already looking forward to the story
around casca highbottom the
unintentional creator of The Hunger
Games whether we will also get to
experience the beginnings through
flashbacks remains to be seen sadly we
haven't had a chance to see any moving
images yet but we did get to see a first
teaser however it only shows a snake and
a bird since it's still almost a year
before the film is released we will have
to wait a little more to get a first
trailer but as always you'll be able to
watch it here on our Channel
well that was it all the information
about the new part of The Hunger Games
but now it's your turn what are you most
excited about the games themselves the
new heroine or maybe the character
development of the future presidents
know let us know Down Below in the
comments and if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up see you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]